bonjour à tous et merci
Monsieur le Directeur d'être venu
pour cette audition sur cette mission
passionnante que nous menons depuis
quelques semaines quelques mois déjà et
dont l'actualité nous a un petit peu
rattrapé cette semaine alors cette
semaine notre mission d'information va
tenir trois auditions publiques celle de
ce matin une autre en fin d'après-midi
pour entendre monsieur Stanislas Bourron
le directeur de la NCT et je vous
rappelle que nous tiendrons demain à
11h15 ça le René Monory une audition
commune avec la commission des lois pour
entendre monsieur Yannick Mores le maire
de Saint-Brevin qui a annoncé sa
démission jeudi dernier alors pour le
moment nous vous entendons Monsieur
Olivier Jacob vous êtes directeur du
management de l'Administration
territoriale et de l'encadrement
supérieur du ministère de l'Intérieur et
des autres mères et je remercie vraiment
votre présente présence ainsi que celle
de vos collaborateurs
ce directeur se penchait sur l'avenir
des communes et des mers impose
nécessairement de faire le point sur
leur relation avec l'État déconcentrés
une mission de contrôle assistance
juridique attribution de fonds
instruction des appels à projets
l'ingéniorité territoriale les
préfectures jouent un rôle essentiel
auprès des communes et nous avons
souvent entendu au cri de nos auditions
louées la figure du sous-préfet comme
interlocuteur de référence des mers mais
dans le même temps nos interlocuteurs se
sont souvent aussi inquiétés de la
faiblesse des moyens de l'État
territorial ou d'un déséquilibre entre
l'activité d'assistance juridique et
celle de censure et plusieurs on fait
part aussi de leur crainte d'un
désengagement progressif de l'État sur
les territoires alors afin d'évoquer
avec vous toutes ces thématiques que
nous avons transmis un questionnaire et
vous pourrez bien sûr compléter par
écrit les réponses que vous nous
apporterez aujourd'hui au travers de ce
questionnaire et avant de vous donner la
parole pour un premier échange je vais
laisser à notre rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente merci
collègue présent et merci Monsieur le
Directeur c'est toujours avec beaucoup
de plaisir que nous éditionnons la démat
parce que c'est une direction qui nous
apporte toujours beaucoup de solutions
j'ai souvenirs je vous l'avais dit déjà
la dernière fois que lors de 3DS vous
aviez
soumis beaucoup de d'éléments qui
s'étaient avérés plus qu'utile et que
nous avions d'ailleurs repris ici même
au Sénat je pense notamment à l'Office
français de la biodiversité enfin
beaucoup de choses qui vont selon nous
et selon la philosophie de nos travaux
dans le bon sens considérant qu'il y a
une appétence forte et une envie
exprimée par par les élus des
territoires de voir cet état territorial
être réarmé et je fais écho à ce que
disait à l'instant la présidente Marie
scarer notamment par le prisme et par le
biais des des
préfet alors il est un paradoxe et qu'on
vient de réouvrir quelques
sous-préfectures mais que le constat est
criant d'un besoin de voir ses
sous-préfectures être remplies de femmes
et d'hommes qui sont des serviteurs de
l'État territorial et qui ont la
capacité justement à nourrir ce lien
précieux avec les avec les élus parce
qu'en revanche nous inquiétons un peu de
voir une forme de de distance je mets le
mot entre guillemets
s'opérer du fait notamment de cette
politique
d'agents
considérant que l'élu est un peu perdu
dans les méandres d'un état territorial
avec une personne qu'il considère être
naturellement comme la porte de l'entrée
de l'État sur les territoires à savoir
le préfet et également je l'évoquais à
l'instant les sous-préfets mais ce
phénomène d'agentilisation avec la NCT
dont je dois le dire en mesure assez
difficilement
[Musique]
et la capacité d'être incarné sur les
territoires et un petit problème
d'agilité alors c'est surtout pas le
président la présidente et le rapporteur
qu'il le disent mais très souvent les
préfets de région de département voir
les sous-prés qui nous le disent parce
que la NCT prend des formes très
différentes
un exemple nous étions dans dans les
vols où on a vu par exemple que dans les
Vosges c'est le sous-préfet de
Neufchâteau qui est chargé de faire
fonctionner la NCT et lequel sous préfet
était absent depuis 6 mois donc on voit
bien en Ille-et-Vilaine on a un peu le
sentiment aussi que tout ça est assez
compliqué enfin tout ça pour dire que
les outils qui permettent justement
notamment d'accompagner par le biais de
l'ingénierie les communes ne relèvent
pas de l'évidence et par ailleurs le
besoin réaffirmé d'avoir parce qu'on est
singulièrement depuis la crise des
gilets jaunes le covid dans un besoin de
réactivité le souci permanent d'avoir un
interlocuteur ou une interlocutrice au
niveau de l'État qui est justement cette
réactivité cette agilité et là encore
c'est un autre des sujets
[Musique]
on souhaiterait nous que le préfet
puisse on l'avait d'ailleurs souligné
dans 3ds cette
coordonnateur des services de de l'État
sur sur le territoire et ça pour nous
c'est quelque chose d'important ça
rejoint ce que je disais sur le
s'agissant de l'eau FP voilà un peu
quelle est la philosophie donc connaître
un peu votre vos positions sur sur ces
sujets et ces quelques questions comment
on peut réarmer cet état territorial
considérant que ce n'est pas qu'un sujet
qui relève de la volonté de l'État parce
qu'on le voit c'est ok la dernière fois
moi j'ai dans ma sous-préfecture à
Tournon-sur-Rhône un service
des impôts qui devaient accueillir 50
personnes on voit bien aujourd'hui la
complexité que cela revêt de recruter
c'est ses agents pour compléter celles
et ceux qui doivent arriver de
l'administration centrale ou d'autres ou
d'autres territoires donc il y a il y a
plusieurs problématiques le sujet n'est
pas monofactorielle mais voilà on sent
que c'est un c'est un besoin qui a un
besoin d'écoute au plus proche des
territoires et puis encore une fois un
besoin de de réactivité puis surtout je
voudrais bien connaître j'aimerais bien
connaître votre sujet et votre position
pardon sur cette question de
l'agenceisation parce que c'est un c'est
un des sujets centraux qui qui ressort
en tout cas comme tel des différentes et
des nombreuses auditions nombreux
échanges que nous avons pu avoir y
compris sur les sur les territoires je
vous remercie
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez vous avez par vos
propos ouverts une multitude de sujets
qui sont des sujets de préoccupation de
la direction à la tête de laquelle je me
trouve et je vais donc revenir sur
certaines des thématiques que vous avez
abordées en essayant de les mettre
toujours dans la perspective de la
mission qui est la vôtre c'est-à-dire
celle du
du rôle du maire de la commune et du
lien entre le représentant de l'État qui
soit préfet ou qu'il soit sous préfet et
donc ce lien entre le représentant de
l'État et le maire
d'abord j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire devant
des commissions ou des missions
concernant les moyens attribués à l'état
territorial
[Musique]
plus forte soit par des réductions
d'effectives soit par des transferts de
missions qui auparavant étaient assurés
dans les sous-préfectures moi quand j'ai
débuté ma carrière une sous-préfecture
délivrée des titres c'est un petit sujet
d'actualité en ce moment sur les cartes
d'identité des passeports
sous-préfecture faisait du contrôle de
l'égalité une sous-préfecture délivrée
Descartes grises et ainsi de suite
donc en effet cette diminution a été
plus forte
à certains endroits que d'autres et dans
les autres services territoriaux de
l'État et départementaux de l'État je
pense à ce qu'on appelle les DDI les
directions départementales
interministérielles la diminution a été
encore plus accentuée
simplement
cette diminution des effectifs a été
stoppée en tout cas en ce qui concerne
le ministère de l'Intérieur depuis
l'année
2021 que je ne dise pas de bêtises en
effet à son arrivée
Gérald Darmanin a décidé d'arrêter la
réduction des effectifs dans le réseau
préfectoral on a donc connu deux années
blanche 2021-2022 c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
plus de diminution d'effectifs mais il
n'y a pas eu de création d'effectif et
depuis le passage de la locmille la loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur il y a
désormais une recréation d'emplois dans
la réseau préfectoral ça ne compense pas
les 4700 et TP supprimer ça représente
équivalentes en plein sur la durée de la
loopmie 2023 2027 c'est donc une rupture
avec une décennie de réduction
d'effectifs
moi je vois le verre à moitié plein bien
sûr dans mon dialogue avec les
organisations syndicales
représentatif des personnels de
préfecture elle regrette qu'on ne crée
pas plus d'effectifs mais néanmoins
c'est quand même une première depuis
depuis plus de 10 ans et ça va nous
permettre de reconquérir de réarmer
l'état territorial pour reprendre
l'expression
qui est maintenant partagée
et notamment de réinvestir certaines
missions et des missions qui ont
souffert au cours de l'année 2010-2020
on peut songer aux missions liées à la
sécurité à la prévention de la
délinquance ça concerne plutôt les
cabinets de préfet aux missions liées à
l'immigration ou également de réarmer
certaines sous-préfectures mais cela
rapporteur vous avez évoqué
la réouverture de certaines
sous-préfectures pour être précises on
ne rouvre pas des sous-préfectures en
fait on remet des sous-préfet dans des
sous-préfectures qui n'ont pas disparu
le président de la République
c'est même déplacé au mois de novembre
dernier à Château-Gontier et on a donc
rouvert cinq sous-préfecture on a même
recréé pour nos compatriotes d'outre-mer
on a même créé un arrondissement complet
à Saint-Georges de loyapoc
en Guyane
et donc ça c'est
ces symboliques d'un réarmement de
l'État départemental notre préoccupation
néanmoins on le redit en
interministériel c'est que ce mouvement
soit également bien accompagné par les
autres ministères ministères de
l'Intérieur fait un effort nous sommes
plus attentifs aux efforts que peuvent
faire les autres ministères présents
dans les départements ministères de la
transition écologique ministère de
l'Agriculture ministère des affaires
sociales pour l'essentiel
je sais pas si vous les auditionnerait
mais on n'est plus circonspect
sur la récréation d'effectifs concernant
ces ministères qui ont plutôt eu
tendance et la Cour des comptes là aussi
la souligner à se reposer sur leur
échelon régional que sur leur échelon
départemental il y a des choix
stratégiques qui ont été faits par ces
ministères notamment au moment de la
création des directions départementales
interministériel elles sont anciennes
maintenant elles ont été créées en 2010
et on voit bien que ces ministères
voyant désormais qu'au niveau
départemental les sujets étaient
interministérialisés ont préféré eux au
niveau des ministères investir sur
l'échelon sur l'échelon régional
sur
peut-être la les conséquences des crises
récentes sur le lien entre les
représentants de l'État et puis et puis
les mères c'est vrai que notre pays à
traverser depuis quelques années des
crises profondes vous avez vous-même
cité la crise du covid on pourrait
auparavant citer la crise des gilets
jaunes plus récemment également la crise
de l'accueil des réfugiés Ukrainiens ou
encore plus récemment la qualifierai pas
de crise mais les manifestations
liées à la réforme des retraites et à
chacune de ces à chacun de ces
événements le lien entre les
représentants de l'État préfet sous
préfet et les mers
échelons s'il en est de proximité c'est
resserré on a beaucoup cité aux sortir
de la crise covid
le lien mère préfet moi je l'ai connu à
l'époque j'étais préférée des Alpes de
Haute c'est vrai que
au moment du covid beaucoup
d'administration en fait ont fermé le
rideau
je les citerai pas par commisération
pour ces administrations mais celle en
tout cas l'administration qui qui est
restée d'active c'est bien le cœur
régalien de l'État la préfecture les
services de police de gendarmerie mais
aux côtés à leur côté les mers qui si on
y revient sont à la fois élus dans leur
circonscription communale mais sont
aussi des représentants de l'État j'aime
à le redire
le maire est un représentant de l'État
et exerce pour le compte de l'État un
certain nombre de missions c'est ce qui
explique sans doute ce lien fort entre
entre les préfets les sous-préfets et
les mers
vous avez cité madame la Présidente
parfois le je suis revenu sur le
désengagement de l'État on pourra
approfondir évidemment
sur le déséquilibre qui pouvait y avoir
entre assistance juridique et censure
c'est le mot que vous avez employé alors
j'imagine que derrière censure vous
faites peut-être référence au contrôle
de l'égalité ou peut-être aussi parfois
à l'exercice
tatillon de la règle
c'est un enfin moi une réalité à
laquelle je me suis confronté à la fois
en tant que préfet et puis au cours de
ma carrière en tant que secrétaire
général de préfecture sans vous refaire
toute ma carrière avant d'exercer dans
les Alpes de Haute-Provence j'exerçais
comme secrétaire général de la
préfecture du Nord secrétaire général de
la préfecture de l'Hérault secrétaire
général de la préfecture du Calvados
rappelant toujours d'ailleurs que le
secrétaire général de préfecture est le
sous-préfet de l'arrondissement
chef-lieu j'ai toujours été très
attentif à maintenir également le lien
quand j'étais secrétaire général de
préfecture avec les élus ce qui m'est
remonté souvent
c'est justement l'application
mais je veux dire tatillonne de la règle
qui bloque un moment donné les dossiers
que souhaite mener le maire parce que
notre corpus administratif est ainsi
fait que
nous avons un certain nombre de règles
en termes de protection environnementale
de protection des monuments historiques
de la police de l'eau
en termes de défrichement de destruction
d'espèces protégées qui font que
lorsqu'un maire souhaite mener un projet
il est
il est souvent confronté à l'application
d'accord plus administratif foisonnant
et devant lequel il est parfois un peu
un peu perdu moi ce que j'ai toujours
essayé de faire et puis c'est ce qu'on
promeut au niveau de la démat la
direction à la tête de laquelle je me
trouve c'est c'est l'accompagnement en
fait des élus et singulièrement des mers
et c'est accompagnement est d'autant
plus nécessaire je pense que l'on se
trouve
à des communes de taille modestes ou
dans des départements ruraux moi ce qui
m'a frappé
la ruralité elle se trouve partout
peut-être pas à Paris dans les
départements de la petite couronne mais
dans un département comme le Nord qu'on
qualifie volontiers d'Urbain il y a de
la ruralité également et il y a des
maires de petites communes ce qui m'a
souvent frappé c'est
oui le dénuement des mères face à
l'application de cette règle et là c'est
le rôle du représentant de l'État que
d'accompagner le maire à la fois dans
cette ingénierie administrative et en
termes d'ingénierie financière dans
votre questionnaire vous posez notamment
la question des subventions
d'investissement type DETR et des cils
et des subventions qui se sont
multipliées c'est en dernier on pourra y
revenir là aussi si vous le souhaitez et
lorsque
je suis arrivé dans les Alpes de de
Haute-Provence qu'on a essayé de mener
avec les élus Association des Maires le
Conseil départemental c'est de mettre en
place un guichet unique pour accompagner
les mers un guichet unique en terme de
réglementation théâtre dès que le maire
a un projet c'est qu'il puisse venir
s'adresser
à la préfecture ou à la sous-préfecture
pour savoir ce à quoi il doit s'attendre
les les obstacles qui peut-être
ce montrant devant son projet j'ai en
tête des projets qui me reviennent
notamment en termes d'énergie
renouvelable lorsqu’un maire souhaite
pas tellement pas tellement les
éoliennes mais lorsque un notamment dans
la partie méridionale de la France un
maire souhaite monter un projet de de
panneaux photovoltaïques
il y a un certain nombre de
réglementations qui s'appliquent ou même
dans les
[Musique]
dans les pays de montagne madame la
Présidente un maire qui souhaiterait
monter une micro centrale
hydroélectrique là on peut être sûr que
la police de l'eau viendra
peut-être compliqué le projet le projet
du maire donc il y a quand même des
solutions qui existent pour accompagner
l'élu et puis c'est toujours moi ce que
j'ai cru faire en sorte que le préfet le
sous-préfet soit l'intermédiaire entre
les ingénieurs d'État que l'on trouve
notamment au sein des directions
départementales des territoires et les
élus n'ont pas pour déroger à la règle
le sous-préfet le préfet moi c'est pas
comme ça que j'ai conçu mon rôle n'est
pas là pour
déroger à la règle mais pour parfois
l'expliquer et puis ensuite aussi
parfois
accompagné dans la partie
d'interprétation de la règle qui existe
parce que tous nos codes ne sont pas
aussi précis qu'on pourrait le croire
change notamment à des dossiers auxquels
j'ai dû faire face notamment quand
j'étais dans le Calvados sur toutes les
réglementations applicables
au risque inondations ou puisque j'ai
exercé dans plusieurs départements
littoraux toutes les réglementations
applicables à la loi littorale ou à la
loi montagne sachant que la loi
littorale en plus on peut la retrouver
en montagne lorsqu'on a des lacs et
le pire c'est quand on est sujet mais je
pense que vous connaissez ça très très
bien malin présidente à la fois la loi
littoral et à la loi montagne qui se
conjugue et qui rendent ainsi difficile
le développement de projet parfois de
développement touristique tout
simplement je l'ai connu quand j'étais
dans le 04 notamment sur les bords du
lac de Serre-Ponçon ou du lac de
Sainte-Croix
donc il y a des solutions quand je vous
parlais de guichet unique dédié au
projet on s'est inspiré tout simplement
de choses qui avaient été faites
notamment dans le département de la
Lozère qui avait été
précurseur en matière de montage de ces
de ces guichets uniques
pour pas être trop long et permettre
ensuite l'échange avec vous
monsieur le rapporteur revenir sur
le sujet de l'agent civilisation de
l'agence ification
qui est un mâle contre lequel nous on
essaie de lutter à la démat parce que
nous sommes très attachés
en fait à l'unité de l'action de l'État
simplement il faut reconnaître
et ça continue d'une certaine manière
depuis là aussi une quinzaine d'années
les agences se sont multipliés et au fur
et à mesure que les agences se
multiplient le combat de la démat on en
a déjà parlé d'ailleurs tous les deux ça
a été de d'essayer d'obtenir qu'à tout
le moins le préfet soit le délégué
territorial des agences inscrits on l'a
obtenu pour des agences importantes pour
l'enrue en termes de renouvellement
urbain pour Lana c'est important pour
les territoires ruraux en termes
d'amélioration de l'habitat lors de la
loi 3DS
non sans mal et avec le soutien des
sénateurs
nous l'avons obtenu également pour
l'ADEME pour
les agences de l'eau
et pour le FB
néanmoins comme je le dis souvent à mes
équipes ça les fait sourire
moi je pratique une une politique qui
est celle du petit pas népalais pour les
montagnards quand vous souhaitez
atteindre le sommet il faut y aller pas
après pas et c'est ainsi qu'on arrive
qu'on arrive au sommet et ne jamais
perdre son objectif de vue donc il y a
encore il y a encore des combats à mener
sur la désignation du préfet comme
délégué territorial on pourrait songer à
des agences comme voie des opérateurs de
l'État
tel que Pôle Emploi tel que le serema
qui est également une agence importante
en termes d'ingénierie
je n'ose évoqué sinon je risque de me
faire taper sur les doigts des agences
qui parfois ont des compétences en
matière de santé publique je signale
néanmoins
dans le cadre de la loopnie une avancée
qui est tout de même une avancée
importante
là aussi obtenu grâce au soutien des
parlementaires
c'est si j'ai bonne mémoire
l'article 23 de la loopmie qui confie au
préfet le pouvoir en cas de crise
le pouvoir hiérarchique sur l'ensemble
des services et opérateurs de l'État
pour la résolution de la crise
évidemment et ça c'est un pas juridique
de franchi qui
vous a peut-être échappé mais qui est
une avancée conceptuelle extrêmement
forte le préfet jusqu'à l'or avait un
pouvoir de coordination des services de
l'État et des opérateurs de l'État
évidemment en cas de crise mais là on
franchit une nouvelle étape parce que le
que j'ai fait pour la résolution de la
crise et on s'est inspiré bien
évidemment de ce que c'était passé au
moment du covid
le préfet a bien pouvoir hiérarchique
sur l'ensemble des services et
opérateurs de l'État y compris par
exemple ce que le préfet n'a pas en
temps normal sur les services chargés de
l'éducation nationale on l'a vu du covid
les difficultés enfin moi je les ai
connus sur le terrain qu'on pouvait
avoir sur les rouvertures les fermetures
de classe de collège et là le préfet
entrer en dialogue avec le directeur
académique des services de l'éducation
nationale là avec cette nouvelle
disposition le préfet pourra toujours
être en dialogue dans un premier temps
mais pourra
être
pour avoir beaucoup plus de manettes je
pense
en termes de résolution de la crise mais
n'en demeure pas moins que sur les
agences en temps normal il y a encore
sans doute des progrès à faire
alors que le Président de la République
lui porte un discours qui est très clair
sur le les responsabilités qu'il
souhaite confier au préfet
il a encore dit lorsqu'il a réuni les
préfets lorsque le président de la
République a réuni les préfets au mois
de septembre 2022 lui président de la
République souhaite avoir un responsable
pour le compte de l'État dans les
territoires simplement dans les dans les
discussions interministérielles cette
volonté présidentielle parfois du mal à
se traduire face à
des perceptions différentes de la part
des de la part des ministères je voulais
attirer votre attention également dans
cette conception
unitaire de l'action de l'État sur ce
qu'on appelle les feuilles de route des
préfets
c'est le premier ministre Castex qui
avait porté
ces nouvelles dispositions qu'on a déjà
connues par le passé on parfois appelé
ça projet territorial de l'État ou plan
d'action stratégique de l'État dans les
départements
la feuille de route du préfet c'est par
la signature du premier ministre des
objectifs qui sont fixés au préfet de
région et au préfet de départements
des objectifs en matière de politique
publique de l'État les feuilles de route
des préfets je sais pas si vous avez
déjà eu l'occasion de les consulter
certains préfions communiquer sur leur
feuille de route elles sont constituées
de deux parties il y a une partie
descendante c'est ce qu'on appelait
au cours du premier mandat les objets de
la vie quotidienne les ovécues
maintenant on appelle ça les politiques
prioritaires du gouvernement les PPG
sont des priorités déterminées par les
ministères donc c'est plutôt descendant
et puis il y a une deuxième partie qui
est plutôt ascendante ce sont les
projets
du préfet que le préfet considère comme
prioritaire pour son pour son
département et la juxtaposition des deux
constitue ces feuilles de route qui sont
valables là pour 21 22 et 23 et le
dernier comité interministériel pour la
transformation publique le CIPP qui
s'est tenu la semaine dernière sous la
présidence sur la présidente pardon de
la première ministre et Elisabeth borne
a annoncé une nouvelle génération de
feuilles de route pour la période 24 25
et 26 et ça permet ainsi avec cette
feuille de route là aussi de donner au
préfet
un magistère
moral supplémentaire sur des politiques
publiques qui parfois lui échappent
parce que dans certaines des politiques
publiques descendante que j'ai évoquées
il y a des politiques qui relèvent du
ministère de la Justice du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale du ministère des
finances publiques pour ne citer que
cela et qui sont des ministères qui
échappent normalement à l'autorité
hiérarchique du préfet
je vais peut-être m'arrêter là parce que
je parle comme je parle beaucoup je
pourrais je pourrais continuer on
pourrait évoquer ce que notamment les
dotations de l'investissement
le souci d'ingénierie également le
signal génial public le rôle de la NCT
mais peut-être que je pourrais revenir à
la faveur de vos questions
oui tout à fait merci merci beaucoup en
tout cas pour pour ces éléments et ces
chiffres intéressants
réalisent vraiment combien aussi l'état
territorial a pu être démunie au fil du
temps alors avant de donner la parole à
nos collègues moi je reviendrai sur la
déconcentration effectivement on a
l'impression que depuis quelques temps
puis quelques années on est allé à
l'envers on est parti à l'envers de la
déconcentration contraire les préfets
ont peut-être aujourd'hui plus les pieds
points liés par rapport à leur action
départementale
j'ai
eu une petite expérience la semaine
dernière où j'étais convoquée invitée à
participer à la Commission de
d'attribution du fdva2 le fond
départemental de la vie associative et
où je me suis rendu compte que pour
attribuer ce FDV à deux
la commission faisait remonter ces
propositions au préfet de région alors
je suis pas certaine que pour décider
d'accorder 800 euros un petit festival
du coin ou à apporter un peu
d'accompagnement à une association
l'échelon régional soit le plus
important et le plus le plus
symboliquement
adapté mais bon j'ai découvert ça et je
trouve que c'est assez symbolique
aujourd'hui de la déconcentration
inversée sur sur la campagnement je
souscris complètement à ce que vous avez
dit il y en assiste on a une petite
tendance effectivement sur les
territoires aujourd'hui à plus
d'accompagnement plutôt que la censure
plus accompagnement des élus en essayant
de trouver des solutions
sur le département des Hautes-Pyrénées
on a même pressé de l'époque Rodric
curcy qui avait proposé un accélérateur
de projet sur le ça me fait penser à ça
avec votre guichet unique pour accélérer
les projets dans le cadre du plan de
relance et pour consommer les crédits du
plan de relance il avait proposé
ce guichet unique ou tous les services
de l'État se mettaient autour de la
table pour accélérer au maximum les
projets et pas perdre de temps et là
aussi ce qu'on a constaté avec nos nos
auditions et nos déplacements c'est que
l'accompagnement
et parfois inégal en fonction des
territoires et aussi les interprétations
et les applications des lois peut être
aussi peuvent être aussi ressentis comme
inégal par rapport un territoire vous
avez parlé de l'hydroélectricité moi
j'ai des hydroélectriciennes en
département qui me disent dans notre
département on peut rien faire alors que
dans les Alpes ils peuvent tout faire
voilà donc c'est peut-être se ressenti
de cette inégalité par rapport à
l'accompagnement sur les territoires
qu'il faut aussi revoir
donc sur on va peut-être enchaîner les
questions je sais pas si tu as
merci
effectivement moi je voulais vous poser
une question sur l'ordonnance du mois de
janvier qui a supprimé le corps
préfectoral d'après ce que nous
entendons comme information
le corps préfectoral supprimé à partir
de janvier amènerait donc les préfets en
place à ne pas pouvoir rester en place
plus de 5 ans dans un même poste et plus
de 9 ans dans le même corps ce qui fait
que à terme alors vous parliez de cette
transversalité entre les différents
ministères nous aurions comme préfet ou
sous préfet des fonctionnaires qui
viendraient du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale ou d'autres ministères bien
sûr je cite celui-là en exemple
ne pensez-vous pas que ces
préjudiciables
au travail très très étroit que les élus
appellent de leurs vœux avec les préfets
et ce que vous pensez que la formation
sera suffisante enfin pour pour nous élu
nous que ça avec un peu d'inquiétude
vous le cachons pas quand effectivement
une forme de guichet unique ce serait
peut-être intéressant parce qu'il a été
évoqué là le plan de relance la décile
relance la DETR la décile aujourd'hui
c'est le fond vert et les élus sont
particulièrement perdus sachant qu'il y
a de l'argent
peut-être
et qu'il faut en profiter mais comment
faire donc effectivement ce guichet
unique pourrait-il s'appliquer à ce
genre de subventions et de dotation de
l'État merci
Jean-Marc Boyer oui merci
la
proposition que vous faites de que vous
avez certainement expérimenté de guichet
unique et certains intéressantes mais
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que
ces derniers jours dans les difficultés
qui peut y avoir
pour plusieurs mers c'est tout d'abord
la solitude du maire et le dénuement du
maire face l'ensemble des contraintes
qui peut leur lui être imposées et
moi la question que je me pose c'est de
de savoir quelle garde-fou on peut
mettre garde-fou au sens
propre peut-être même au sens figuré
j'en sais rien on peut mettre entre les
citoyens et le maire et entre
l'administration et le maire
parce qu'aujourd'hui
il se sent quand même un peu démuni face
à l'ensemble des contraintes
administratives surtout je pense au
nouveau maire qui arrive et qui sont
quand même
surpris et perturbé par l'ensemble des
contraintes qui leur sont imposées et le
deuxième point c'est
le manque de pouvoir décision au fur et
à mesure des années que le maire n'a
plus et l'exemple que donnait madame la
Présidente tout à l'heure sur le SDEA en
particulier qui est intervenu les deux a
été mis en place quand la fameuse
réserve alimentaire a été supprimée et
que on a inclus le DA avec des
subventions aux associations qui ne sont
plus à la main ni des parlementaires ni
des mers d'ailleurs et c'est assez
désespérant on arrive à une réunion
présidée par le préfet
où on a un ensemble de subventions qui
sont attribués un petit peu on se
demande des fois même un peu comment et
enfin bref il y a apparemment toute une
organisation qui est mise en place mais
aussi bien le parlementaire que les mers
sont
je dirais écarté ou à étranger à
l'ensemble des décisions qui peuvent
être prises c'est encore une fois une
perte de pouvoir décision
et je ne parlerai pas de la terre pour
les subventions attribuées pour des
montants de subventions de moins de
100.000 euros ou effectivement c'est
encore aussi une fois à la main du
représentant de l'État et là aussi les
parlementaires bon on discute un peu
avec le maire qui sous préfet etc mais
il n'y a pas véritable pouvoir de
décision qui peut être et moi je pense
que une retour d'une dotation d'action
parlementaires au niveau des
départements alors certes pas comme un
appui existait par le passé mais avec
une concertation qui serait mise en
place avec l'ensemble des parlementaires
et les services de l'État permettrait je
pense de d'avoir une une reprise en main
un petit peu de l'ensemble des de cette
proposition d'ailleurs déposée
une profession de loi dans ce sens là
mais il faut que absolument on essaye de
retrouver du pouvoir de décision
entre avec le maire et des
parlementaires du département
merci Cécile Kerman oui merci pour vos
propos introductifs je vais dire en
préalable que j'ai pas de souci
particulier avec la préfectoral dans mon
département mais néanmoins et quand on
discute avec les mères même si je
partage ce qui a été dit je crois qu'on
observe depuis quelques temps une
certaine inflexion sur une présence sur
le terrain en tout cas de la part des
différents sous préfets plus fortes et
plus importante qu'elle n'a été en tout
cas par le passé si on remonte à une
dizaine d'années
néanmoins les ressentis demeurent alors
tout d'abord
l'appréciation et la facilité de travail
avec les différents services de la
préfectorale c'est deux dernières années
ont été facilités et on peut le dire y
compris dans les suites du plan de
relance avec tout de même des enveloppes
budgétaires qui ont aussi permis compris
à la électorale de mieux accompagner les
élus et aux élus d'avoir le sentiment
d'être mieux accompagné
j'attends de voir sur les deux années
qui viennent et la redistribution de ces
mêmes dotations avec des enveloppes qui
parfois sont un peu plus réduites sur ce
comment se ressenti et évoluera
je pense que sur les élus savent qu'il y
a des normes des réglementations qui
peuvent être à un moment donné
effectivement
d'ailleurs parfois partager par
eux-mêmes voilà de préserver quoi je
gère sur les ongles on va dire
préservation de l'environnement au sens
très large mais il me semble que et
peut-être parfois par faute de temps par
faute de moyens effectivement toute
cette notion d'un accompagnement
initial et les plus anciens aiment à
rappeler le temps béni de la DDE
qui était réellement en accomp deux
proximité en amont et qui finalement
sécurisé et compris les élus dans leur
capacité à porter des projets parce
qu'ils savaient non pas qu'on allait les
empêcher pour le principe de les
empêcher mais que en tout cas on dirait
ce qui est possible pas possible et que
donc quand on arrivera un dossier
finalisé il serait entre guillemets sans
risque juridique et je crois que ça se
renforce encore plus parce que la
judiciarisation aujourd'hui de notre
société fait que nous avons aussi des
élus qui parfois sont pardonnez-moi
l'expression un peu en panique à l'idée
de se dire que si quelque chose est mal
fait
demain un citoyen ou de la même
d'ailleurs de l'État un citoyen
n'importe qui peut attaquer et peut
faire
s'effondrer le projet donc je crois
qu'il y a aussi ça dans ce besoin de
sécurisation en tout cas me semble-t-il
qui est attendu par les différents
services de l'État et puis sur un
deuxième champ que vous avez évoqué qui
est quand même l'enjeu de de
accompagnement de la décentralisation
qui a été la déconcentration on décerte
on ne va pas disserter ici sur la
déconcentration globalement mais il y a
t-il eu réellement une décentration ou
finalement une dislocation de la
représentation de l'État dans les
territoires et vous l'avez vous l'avez
dit certains ministères font le choix
d'une hyper départementalisation de leur
déconcentrations d'autres plutôt d'une
régionalisation
et quand je dis faut le choix compris
parce que une majorité parlementaire il
y a incité je n'ai pas que c'est un
choix individuel de de chaque ministère
et finalement d'une lecture d'abord très
complexe parce qu'on ne sait plus si
c'est à l'échelle départementale ou
régionale et les exemples qui viennent
d'être évoqués ne serait-ce que sur le
fond de la vie associative qui lui est à
l'échelle régionale la des cils aussi
mais la Deux Terres départements rien
que sur ce champ là voilà et sur toutes
les autres les autres sujets et pose la
question des agences là aussi c'est à
dire que finalement quand on compte j'ai
envie de dire les troupes il reste
encore un peu de monde sur sur les
territoires mais avec des statues avec
des hiérarchies et des échelles
géographiques très différentes qui en
tout cas je pense contribue à pour ma
part à affaiblir y compris l'action d'un
état déconcentré et puis vous me
permettrait tout de même de souligner
que au-delà de juger les agences les
évolutions aussi de statues quand même
des personnels font que dans celui de la
fonction publique d'État est attaché
pour certains beaucoup d'avantages mais
en tout cas celui du sens du service de
la République et de ses valeurs je
m'interroge quand même parfois sur dans
certaines agences effectivement on est
animé par un projet par la défense de
tel ou telle secteur d'activité mais
peut-être un peu moins que quand on
était fonctionnaire d'État sur la
volonté en tout cas d'un intérêt général
qui est confronté au réel et donc qui
doit répondre à des enjeux et à des
principes et à la loi mais qui
confrontait au réel doit pouvoir tout de
même s'adapter et prendre en compte la
réalité pour la transformer
Monsieur Arnaud
oui madame monsieur le président
de trois observations d'abord une
demande de précision au vu des propos
que vous avez tenu ce Jacob il y a
quelques minutes quand vous avez indiqué
que chaque préfet disposait ce qui n'est
pas une surprise pour nous une feuille
de route et que certains visiblement la
communiquer d'autres ne la
communiquaient pas je trouve qu'il
serait particulièrement intéressant
notamment pour les parlementaires de
chacun de nos départements de connaître
de manière très précise et public avec
un systématisme du porta connaissance de
cette feuille de route ce qui
permettrait à la fois de connaître la
feuille de route fixée par le National
au préfet et puis la compréhension que
le préfet peut avoir ou la préfète peut
avoir des enjeux du département et jouer
pour ce qui nous contrôle notre rôle
aussi territorial cette fois-ci non pas
national d'évaluation et de contrôle des
politiques publiques je crois que ce
serait effectivement un élément
particulièrement intéressant pour pour
les parlementaires que nous sommes
sur la question des guichets uniques si
le gay je suis unique tel que vous
l'avez évoqué au titre de votre
expérience dans mon département voisin
parce que je suis des Hautes-Alpes des
albums Provence consiste à ce que le
préfet coordonne les financements des
autres
je pense que c'est un sujet sur lequel
il nécessaire d'approfondir le dialogue
avec les collectivités territoriales
partenaires des financements de nos
collectivités s'il s'agit comme dans mon
département et depuis longtemps d'avoir
une conférence technique entre les chefs
de fil de chacune des collectivités et
le chef de fiche généralement le
secrétaire général ou le sous-préfet
d'arrondissement pour coordonner ne
serait-ce que
la cohérence des plantes financement et
éviter que les trimestres les saisons
s'accumulent pour avoir le
plantinancement bouclé au vu des
co-financeurs là je dis banco et on
pourrait même imaginer dans le cas d'une
concertation active avec nos
associations nationales représentatives
des différentes strates un travail en ce
sens là ce qui permettrait de gagner en
efficacité pour nos politiques publiques
et le financement de nos projets
communaux
un sujet qui me tient à coeur c'est le
rôle du préfet puisque vous avez
valorisé comme souvent dans la sphère
publique dans la communication publique
du gouvernement le tandem mère préfet
j'ai constaté que madame la Première
ministre avait probablement un peu
fourché lors d'une communication
publique en insistant sur le tandem
préfet président d'Interco
et je vous cache pas que
ce n'était pas simplement qu'une erreur
je pense d'appréciation c'est
effectivement un concept nous faisons
dans beaucoup de nos départements la
volonté peut-être par facilité de
travail peut-être par conséquence d'un
manque d'effectif je reviendrai tout à
l'heure la volonté de privilégier
d'abord les présidents au détriment de
la ruralité profonde mais au détriment
aussi de ce qui a été valorisé et bien
heureusement valorisé par le
gouvernement ces dernières années à
travers notamment la labellisation
petite ville de main les réseaux des
vides intermédiaires qui ne sont pas
forcément ces villes
à la tête de l'exécutif des
intercommunalités mais qui constitue
bien souvent un sas utile entre
métropole agglomération et ultra
ruralité pour les services pour les
maisons françaises pour des politiques
de d'installation et développement
intermédiaires je pense qu'il faudrait
envoyer un signe fort au préfet qu'il ne
fasse pas comme la première ministre
privilégié effectivement dans la
pratique du quotidien même faut pas
effectivement rompre les discussions
bien évidemment avec les
intercommunalités mais privilégier ce
tandem et bien gardé comme feuille de
route principale prioritaire le tandem
mer
président maire préférée j'aimerais
également insister ce sera mon dernier
point
sur ce que vous avez évoqué sur le rôle
finalement de coordination active voire
même parfois en cas de crise de
hiérarchie opérationnelle des préfets
sur les services
internes au département moi j'aurais
tendance à dire qu'il faudrait qu'il y
ait qu'une parole d'État dans les
départements
or on a souvent le sentiment nous en
tant qu'élut locaux
qu'il y a plusieurs États dans l'état
Jean-Luc pour preuve le parcours de
combattants pour un maire qui est en
train de réviser son plu dès lors qu'il
n'est pas plu et
lorsqu'il pense avoir atteint la
dernière
barrière à sauter
l'avant veille quasiment de lancer
l'enquête publique on attend l'Agence de
l'environnement régional qui doit
émettre son avis et qui peut
éventuellement contrarié tout le travail
qui a été fait par un partenariat actif
par une coopération active avec les
personnes publiques associées de
proximité dans le département et là
patatra le préfet découvre quasiment en
même temps que l'élu la vie de
l'instance régionale et on se retrouve
dans des situations de tension énorme
donc moi je souhaite effectivement
notamment que les DREAL très clairement
travaille davantage et mieux avec les
préfets de département et qui est une
coordination le très en amont possible
entre l'autorité et préfectorale
départementale les Dréal et notamment
les délais de puisque les mers ont trois
mois
d'aider pour obtenir la vie de l'agence
régionale soit effectivement calé sur
des degrés d'instruction en lien avec la
préfectoral enfin on a évoqué
le renforcement lorsque j'arrivais d'un
certain nombre d'autorités enfin
d'organisation préfectorales avec des
sous-prés je m'en réjouis dans mon
département particulier et c'est une
très bonne chose pour accompagner les
élus locaux ce que je crois c'est qu'il
faut effectivement aussi dès lors que
l'on a des moyens financiers cela a été
évoqué par ma collègue il y a quelques
secondes
conséquent je dois le reconnaître depuis
quelques années avec la dstr les fonds
verts encore faut-il que la machine à
travailler des services de l'État et
nombre de maires me disent service de
l'État dans service de l'État il y a
service alors ce service et défaillant
par manque de moyens humains
d'accompagnement des collectivités dans
le montage leur dossier donc deux fois
que j'entends vous comprenez votre
dossier n'a pas atteint un niveau de
maturité suffisante pour qu'il puisse
être bénéficier de la dotr le degré de
maturité suffisant encore faut-il qu'on
l'explique au maire encore faut-il qu'il
y ait des hommes et des femmes qui
puissent accompagner l'instruction
au-delà de la petite équipe autour du
sous-préfet pour la maturité de ces
dossiers et je pense qu'il faut vraiment
renforcer des secondes lignes dans les
préfectures pour pouvoir effectivement à
côté des DDT apporter le conseil
nécessaire pour l'élaboration des
dossiers et je crois que c'est d'utilité
publique puisque c'est une façon aussi
de mieux consommer les crédits de etr de
mieux consommer le plan de relance qui a
été mis en oeuvre et aussi de faciliter
la relance économique dans les
territoires à travers les PME et TPE qui
qui font vivre au département
merci
vaste programme pour répondre monsieur
directeur c'est autant de autant de
sujets auxquels j'ai pu être confronté à
la fois en territoriale et en centrale
d'abord peut-être un mot sur la notion
de déconcentration que vous avez évoqué
madame la Présidente
nous à la démat enfin la direction à la
tête de laquelle je me trouve on insiste
énormément sur les notions de
déconcentration on est porteurs de
déconcentration
donner davantage de pouvoir au préfet
alors ça peut être et le préfet de
région et le préfet de département tout
à l'heure il y a une remarque vous
citiez l'exemple sur le fdva2 je vais
peut-être y revenir à la décile par
exemple également et
te distribué attribué par le préfet de
région sur proposition des préfets
départements c'est aussi parfois sujet
de discussions voir de tension au sein
de l'appareil d'État entre entre préfet
de région et préfet de département
donc on porte nous en interministériel
les notions de déconcentration
sans être trop techno mais notamment
donner plus de pouvoir d'actions préfet
à la fois en matière RH et en matière
financière au ministère de l'intérieur
on est un ministère très déconcentré
pour les moyens des préfectures à des
sous-préfectures on donne une enveloppe
au préfet de région qui la répartit
entre les préfets de département mais on
ne flèche pas cette enveloppe en
fonction des missions ou en fonction des
des catégories ça n'est pas le cas de
tous les ministères il y a beaucoup de
ministères qui au niveau budgétaire
décide de la répartition des effectifs
depuis la centrale et vont le fléchir
jusqu'au moindre ETP en départemental
donc là il y a encore des progrès à
faire en matière de déconcentration RH
je vous signale un petit outil qui est
peut-être passé inaperçu mais qui est
une vraie nouveauté et qu'on appelle
chez nous la règle du 3%
là aussi je vous renvoie
c'est d'une initiative prise par Jean
Castex à l'occasion du comité
interministériel pour la transformation
publique de Vesoul la règle du 3% ça
donne le pouvoir au préfet de région de
répartir comme ils le souhaitent jusqu'à
3% des effectifs des budgets de
l'administration territoriale de l'État
alors 3% vont bien c'est pas beaucoup
sauf que quand vous faites 3%
[Musique]
et comme vous le disiez madame la
sénatrice il reste quand même du monde
dans l'administration territoriale de
l'État ce sont des milliers d'effectifs
que les les préfets de région peuvent
ainsi déplacer en fonction de leur
priorité d'un ministère à l'autre la
première année d'exercices de cette
règle de 3% c'était 2022 donc les
préfets s'en sont emparés modérément et
on constate en 2023 que désormais les
préfets des régions sont un peu plus
offensifs sur l'utilisation de cette
règle du 3% qui est une vraie novation
l'attention de votre mission qui est une
vraie novation budgétaire
sur peut-être les dotations
d'investissement sur le sénateur disait
tout à l'heure mais les élus décident
pas sur la DETR la DSI le fdva moi je
reviendrai pas sur le sujet de la
réserve parlementaire que j'ai connu en
son temps c'est pas mon rôle de
m'exprimer dessus simplement sur la DETR
les élus
moi j'ai connu l'époque de la DGE de la
DDR avant même la DETR il y a toujours
eu une commission des élus et ensuite à
la fin c'est toujours le préfet qui
décidait simplement l'obligation pour le
préfet de département c'est de se mettre
d'accord avec le président de la
commission des élus sur les priorités
qu'on se fixe
ça peut varier de départements
départements on peut fixer une priorité
sur l'eau potable sur l'assainissement
sur l'accueil des gens du voyage c'est
un sujet toujours oui sur la voirie sur
les écoles évidemment généralement quand
on a mis l'eau potable assainissement
les écoles et la voirie
on a on a saturé la dota puis on ensuite
on détermine d'autres priorités et
charge souvent c'est au secrétaire
général de la préfecture d'aller
défendre ensuite la programmation devant
la Commission des élus réunis auquel on
a rajouté
plus depuis plus récemment les
parlementaires si je ne me trompe voilà
tout à fait mais à la fin c'est toujours
le préfet qui décide c'est bien des
subventions d'investissement de l'État
mais qui sont largement discutés je
pense avec les élus locaux alors c'est
un peu différent pour la des cils qui
est une dotation plus récente et c'est
aussi différent pour le fond vert mise
en place depuis cette année mais moi
dans tous les départements
là aussi il y a des hommes et des femmes
et des pratiques qui sont différentes
mais dans tous les départements je suis
passé la programmation de la DETR était
largement discutée avec les élus et puis
à la fin il y avait peut-être un
arbitrage mais c'était plutôt consensuel
moi je me souviens au sein de la
commission des élus d'autant que le
président de la commission des élus ou
la présidente c'était souvent soit un
sénateur qui avait du poids dans le
département soit le président de
l'Association des Maires
c'est un élu avec lequel il fallait de
toute façon discuter on pouvait pas
faire passer notre programmation comme
ça sans
sans en discuter en revanche c'est vrai
que en tout cas avant la décile et avant
le
fond vert les les enveloppes des etr
étaient souvent insuffisantes pour faire
face de toute façon à toutes les
demandes donc il y a de toute manière
besoin d'un arbitrage à un moment donné
je change un peu de sujet madame la
sénatrice sur la la réforme du corps
préfectoral c'est un sujet intéressant
puisque ma direction a aussi en charge
là je suis un peu en quelque sorte le
DRH des préfets des sous-préfets même si
c'est pas moi à la fin qui prend la
décision puisque les décisions sont
prises par décret du Président de la
République en conseil des ministres pour
les préfets et sans Conseil des
ministres pour les sous-préfet
vous avez évoqué la durée des 5 ans et
des neuf ans la durée des 5 ans je
précise pour les membres de cette
mission il s'agit de ne pas pouvoir
rester pour un sous-préfet plus de 5 ans
sur le même poste
en généralement les élus se plaignent
davantage du turnover des sous-prés que
ou des préfets que d'une durée trop
longue sur leur poste en fait ce qu'on
constate la durée des 5 ans c'est plutôt
le fait de Sous Préfet plutôt en fin de
carrière plutôt au sommet de la pyramide
et qui reste sur leur poste parce qu'ils
espèrent un meilleur avenir le meilleur
avenir étant notamment d'obtenir la
casquette mais la casquette elle vient
pas toujours et ce qui nous a incité à
réformer le statut c'est que souvent
après le sous-préfet il restait 5 ans 6
ans 7 ans 8 ans et parfois les élus
venaient au contraire nous trouver en
disant mais alors ce sous préfet il faut
nous le changer parce que il est en
retraite il est en roue libre il n'est
plus suffisamment dynamique et j'ai des
exemples en tête que je ne peux pas
citer mais mais c'était plutôt le
contraire donc en mettant cette cet
échéance de 5 ans ça oblige à aller
chercher les collègues avec une règle
statutaire qu'on va appliquer pour la
première fois cette année puisque c'est
la première année d'application du
nouveau statut et pour 2023
c'est environ pour vous donner un ordre
de grandeur une douzaine de Sous Préfet
qui sont rattrapés par cette règle des 5
ans et avec laquelle avec lesquels nous
allons entamer nous un dialogue pour les
changer et les mettre sur un autre poste
l'idée c'est pas de les éjecter et de
les mettre au rebut c'est de leur
proposer un autre poste dans la
préfectorale
et ainsi d'avoir pour ces postes les
plus importants un peu plus de rotation
alors les neuf ans c'est la limite de 9
ans d'exercices en territorial quel que
soit le nombre de postes de poste trois
postes quatre postes pour un préfet ou
un sous-préfet c'est à dire qu'un préfet
ou un sous-préfet ne pourra pas exercer
plus de 9 ans territoriale il devra à ce
moment-là statutairement faire une
j'allais dire un break il va pas faire
un break parce qu'il va pas il sait pas
un congé sans solde mais faire quitter
la territoriale pour exercer d'autres
fonctions pendant au minimum deux ans
avant de revenir
pour 9 ans en territoriale petite
subtilité du statut pour le sous-préfet
qui arriverait à se faire nommer
au bout de huit ans les compteurs sont
remis à zéro quand il est préfet
donc on peut dans
on peut dans l'absolu exercer pendant 18
ans en territorial si entre temps on a
réussi on est parvenu à se faire
promouvoir préférer
mais cette règle des 9 ans elle est donc
statutaire elle va commencer à
s'appliquer à partir de
2000 à partir de 2032 puisque le autant
la règle des 5 ans
sans être techno là aussi mais autant la
règle des 5 ans est rétroactive
autant la règle des 9 ans commence à se
computer à partir du 1er janvier 2023 et
donc fera sentir ses premiers effets en
et l'objectif a voulu par le Président
de la République au travers de la
réforme de la haute fonction publique
d'État c'est davantage de mobilité
parmi les hauts fonctionnaires et
notamment d'éviter que certains ont
fonctionnaires ne se spécialisent dans
l'atterritoriale et nous au ministère de
l'intérieur on est très attentif aux
allées et retours entre territorial et
central c'est vraiment une nous on
estime qu'un haut fonctionnaire est
meilleur quand il alterne sa carrière
entre territorial et central même si je
ça n'est forcément pas évident
on a évoqué la monsieur le sénateur la
solitude du maire sont dénumment et on
est rattrapé notamment madame la
Présidente vous l'avez dit par par
l'actualité
au-delà des
garde-fous pour reprendre votre votre
expression notamment qui qui réside dans
le code pénal la ferme médiatique qui
nous occupe
mais en évidence en effet que le maire
de Saint-Brevin aurait pu notamment être
davantage accompagné par par son
sous-préfet
c'est peut-être enfin j'ose le croire
peut-être dans des situations aussi
extrêmes que celle-là l'exception qui
confirme la règle parce que là aussi moi
ce que j'ai pu constater et notamment au
moment du la crise des gilets jaunes et
ça concernait pas uniquement les mères
ça concernait aussi les parlementaires
les représentants de l'État étaient très
attentifs à la protection des élus
représentant de la nation sénateur
mère à partir du moment où des menaces
étaient
explicites
et donc dans l'affaire qui nous concerne
j'espère qu'on était là plus sur une
exception qui confirme la règle et dans
demeure pas moins et les médias s'en
sont faits les cours récemment
que la pression est plus forte sur les
élus est-ce que c'est
l'individualisation des comportements
est-ce que c'est la médiatisation
également de certaines affaires les
réseaux sociaux
tout ceci combiné et sans doute plus
forte aujourd'hui qu'elle ne l'était il
y a une quinzaine d'années nécessite
donc une plus grande attention des
représentants de l'État lorsque des
menaces se font jour sur le projet que
peut porter un élu ou surtout simplement
ce qu'incarne l'élu je signale au
passage que l'on a constaté également
une recrudescence des atteintes à toutes
les personnes qui incarnent l'autorité
publique là on parle des maires mais on
pourrait parler des sapeurs-pompiers qui
interviennent dans les quartiers facile
des policiers des gendarmes
etc des tout ce qui incarne à un moment
donné au regard du citoyen l'autorité le
citoyen ne faisant pas d'ailleurs la
différence entre les responsabilités
parfois des
des uns et des autres je vous laisse
signaler néanmoins
dans ce lien entre le maire et et le
présentant de l'État que nous sommes
l'un des rares ministères au ministère
de l'Intérieur à avoir
maintenu ce qu'on appelle l'échelon
infra départemental ce qui s'est passé
c'est ces années passées de la part de
certains ministères c'est un reflux
au niveau départemental au mieux au
niveau régional au pire or le ministère
de l'Intérieur lui a maintenu coûte que
coûte sa présence infra départementale
au travers des sous-préfets mais on
pourrait parler aussi au travers des
brigades de gendarmerie ou au travers
des commissariats de police pour évoquer
toute la plénitude de l'implantation du
ministère de l'Intérieur et même si
c'est symbolique on en parlait en début
d'audition le fait de recréer des postes
de Sous Préfet
c'est vraiment un message quand voit le
ministre de l'Intérieur et le
gouvernement plus largement au
territoire ruraux qui ont pu se sentir
abandonné d'une certaine manière par le
l'autorité publique et les retours que
l'on a quand on crée un poste de Sous
Préfet à Château-Gontier à Clamecy à
Nantua à Rochechouart ou à Montdidier
ce sont des échos extrêmement positifs
de la part des mères en fait les
premiers qui réagissent alors c'est bien
sûr le maire du chef-lieu
d'arrondissement mais plus globalement
ce sont les mers qui retrouvent enfin un
interlocuteur pour porter
leur dossiers de subvention les dossiers
les dossiers qui leur sont leur sont
chers un mot sur l'ingénierie public
qui a été qui a été évoqué je crois que
c'est par vous la sénatrice
le regret parfois que nous manifestons
nous
c'est un peu paradoxal vous verrez avec
votre mission c'est que nous on regrette
parfois nous au ministère de l'Intérieur
que l'on déploie énormément de crédit
d'ingénierie publique au profit des
collectivités locales on a créé
énormément de postes de chargées de
mission pour accompagner les projets
actions cœur de ville petite ville de
demain territoire d'industrie
mais on constate en fait que l'État
cofinance énormément de postes au profit
des collectivités locales je ne vous ai
cité que les principaux mais on pourrait
parler des adultes relais des postes
fongèpes des conseillers numériques et
quand on fait le total on s'est livré
parfois à l'exercice en région Normandie
le préfet Pierre-André Durand c'est un
préfet de la région Normandie c'était
livré à l'exercice c'était plus de 200
et TP qui était ainsi co-financés par
l'État au profit des collectivités
locales donc il y a un vrai effort
au-delà des subventions d'investissement
fait par l'État pour porter
des initiatives prises par l'État très
fréquemment au profit des collectivités
locales
nous à la démat nous disons et nous
portons ce discours auprès de la DGCL et
auprès de la NCT qui est peut-être enfin
venu le temps de dégager aussi sur nos
enveloppes un peu de crédit d'ingénierie
au profit du représentant de l'État vous
disiez madame la sénatrice regrettait le
temps de je crois que c'était vous qui
le disiez le temps de l'ingénierie
public que moi j'ai connu en effet des
DD2 et des dafes on ne reviendra pas sur
ce temps de l'ingénierie publique en
revanche il est sans doute possible de
mobiliser des crédits d'ingénierie au
profit du préfet pour le compte des
collectivités ou pour porter tel ou tel
projet
ça ça fait son chemin je crois
progressivement quand vous auditionnerez
Stanislas Bourron ce soir
la DGCL et la NCT progresse sur l'idée
de dégager des enveloppes d'ingénierie
que le préfet de pour immobiliser à sa
main pour telle ou tel projet
je vous signale également la semaine
dernière dans les décisions qui ont été
prises par le citep de Vesoul de qui
s'est tenu à Paris pardon la création
d'experts de haut niveau
dans certains départements on a créé des
postes de sous-préfet d'arrondissement
on a recréé vous le disiez monsieur le
sénateur des postes de sous-préfet dans
les Hautes-Alpes on a créé un poste de
Sous Préfet en tout c'est 30 postes de
Sous Préfet qui ont été ainsi recréés on
a recyclé une partie des postes de
sous-préfet relance en fait et en plus
de ces 30 postes on avait déjà créé 23
postes d'experts de haut niveau pas dans
tous les départements c'est des postes
j'ai en tête par exemple dans les Vosges
ils ont créé un poste d'expérience au
niveau dédié au développement rural
en Bretagne ils ont plutôt créé un poste
d'experts de haut niveau dédiés au
développement de la filière pêche à
Toulouse ça va plutôt être un poste
d'expert du haut niveau pour le
développement de la filière aéronautique
etc et bien le CI TP de la semaine
dernière a décidé de porter ce nombre de
postes d'experts de niveau de 23 à 100
et alors maintenant il faut qu'on
déploie la création de ces postes et
l'idée c'est là aussi de réarmer en
ingénierie les départements
contenus là aussi de la perte
d'ingénierie publique constaté au niveau
des départements et je sais par ailleurs
vous pourrez peut-être là aussi parce
que c'est plutôt lui qu'il porte
interroger Stanislas Bouron qu'on est en
discussion interministérielle pour
développer des postes supplémentaires en
termes de soutien à la ruralité et
notamment de soutien des postes de
chargées de mission
plutôt logés dans les préfectures pour
déployer les différentes dispositions du
plan ruralité du département auquel
Giraud était très attentif récemment et
Dominique fort aujourd'hui avec avec
Monsieur avec Monsieur
sur les feuilles de route monsieur le
sénateur moi je suis tout à fait
favorable à vous communiquer à vous
madame la Présidente la totalité des
feuilles de route des préfets charges
ensuite
si vous le pouvez je pense qu'il y aura
pas de souci allez à les communiquer aux
membres de votre mission et puis plus
largement au sénateur nous on fait la
transparence là-dessus on incite plutôt
les préfets à communiquer leurs feuilles
de route au parlementaire et puis plus
largement aux acteurs du territoire et
ça contribuera en effet monsieur le
sénateur à la mission qui est la vôtre
de contrôle de l'action du pouvoir du
pouvoir exécutif sur le guichet unique
moi l'idée que je portais c'était plutôt
un guichet unique en terme d'ingénierie
de réglementation le préfet il a pas
vocation à faire la politique du coucou
et à s'emparer du financement des autres
en revanche ce que j'ai constaté et ce
qui peut-être s'est fait jour dans un
département c'est l'utilité de faire un
comité des financeurs c'est d'harmoniser
la politique qui est celle du conseil
départemental plus difficile c'est celle
du conseil régional et que c'est déjà
ces trois acteurs conseils régional
conseil départemental se mettent autour
de la table pour un moment donné voir
comment
comment on cofinance le plus
efficacement moi j'ai vu ça se mettre en
place dans des moments difficiles j'ai
eu à présider quand j'étais secrétaire
général de la préfecture de l'Hérault
des comités des financeurs quand il
fallait décider des subventions lors de
la reconstruction après un phénomène
cévenol j'en ai connu de très très
difficile dans l'Hérault et là vous
savez il y a des missions d'expertise
qui viennent des missions d'inspection
qui viennent dans les départements et
qui décident des subventions apportées
par l'État et à l'époque j'avais mis en
place des comités des financeurs
associés en région département et état
et c'est redoutablement efficace et
c'est très apprécié par les par les élus
souvent
peut-être qu'il faut je crois que c'est
plus l'initiative c'est pas
réglementaire il y a des préfets qui en
prennent l'initiative et c'est assez
c'est une idée éventuellement pour la
voie de mission c'est assez efficace si
vous me permettez de réagir par rapport
à ça parce que le sujet c'est que les
lieux il est trop contrebalancé entre ce
qui relève de l'initiative du préfet ce
qui peut être très intéressant mais du
coup quand il change de préfet il perd
tous ses repères et ça ça commence à
devenir un peu je vous le dis un peu
pénible parce qu'on a le sentiment que
l'État crée les conditions de son propre
dysfonctionnement singulièrement sur la
relation préférée de département préfet
de région je vous donne un exemple et et
je vous mets au défi de me trouver un
seul département de France où ça n'est
pas le cas
aujourd'hui pourquoi on maintient une
des cils un fond vert une des etr
convaincue qu'à un moment ou un autre il
va y avoir j'allais dire une porosité
parce qu'on n'aura pas la capacité à
satisfaire tous les projets donc on va
les piocher dans la des cils comme on a
des engagement des agences de l'eau on
va mettre dans la DETR des sujets qui
vont faire permettre de financer l'eau
donc on voit bien qu'il y a une
interpénétration toutes ces enveloppes
mais que de façon très cosmétique l'État
ne veut absolument pas et j'en sais
quelque chose pour avoir été rapporteur
3DS la difficulté qu'on a eue d'admettre
que le préfet de département puisse avec
l'autorisation du préfet de région parce
qu'il a fallu le formuler comme ça parce
qu'il y avait une petite guéguerre entre
préfet de département et région notifié
la décile on dit pas
ça relève pas quand même de quelque
chose de révolutionnaire et ben je vous
le dis moi je le dis et je permettais
moi cet élan un peu passionné et
passionnel parce qu'on a vraiment un
sujet la frustration que si on veut que
les élus s'y retrouvent il faut redonner
de l'agilité je pourrais dire exactement
la même chose pour la NCT on voit que
même les préfets de départements sont un
peu perdus parce qu'ils ne savent pas
comment finalement composé avec la NCT
sur sur l'ingénierie vous avez cité un
exemple nous avons additionné et une
cohésion de le faire plusieurs fois le
préfet durant l'huile n'est pas
favorable clairement il nous l'a dit
encore à Toulouse est-ce que l'État et
son propre outil d'ingénierie considère
que ça c'est rôle des collectivités et
que ça ce n'est pas le rôle de l'État
donc on voit bien que si vous voulez
tout ça relève d'initiative et tant
mieux parce que de toute façon ne
changera pas le fait que ce sont la
volonté de femmes et d'hommes mais je
pense qu'il y aurait un star de ce que
vous dites sur les feuilles de route des
préfets qu'on est quelques points de
passage obligé parce qu'il m'avait
semblé comprendre que les financements
croisés c'était fini or aujourd'hui
parlons de lire il y a plus un préfet
qui en off ou de façon et je regrette
que là aussi moi aujourd'hui je veux
dire ça a disparu c'est à dire qu'on
nous donne les feuilles de route DETR
sans soucier de ce que veut mettre le
département ou la région aujourd'hui ça
ne peut pas fonctionner ça ne peut pas
fonctionner parce qu'on sait très bien
que les mers sinon ne consomment plus
donc on se retrouve avec des
réaffectations à l'automne d'un bout de
terre qui a pas été consommé parce que
le maire n'a pas eu sa dotation du
département et des pertes de terre donc
vous voyez je trouve qu'en réalité dans
vos propos et c'est pour ça que j'aime
bien vous entendre on a le sentiment que
tous les ingrédients sont sur la table
et que tout est là et que tout pourrait
bien fonctionner mais concret et donc je
vais poser une question
volontairement provocatrice est-ce que
l'État central
ne fait pas quelque part tout pour que
l'État territorial reste quand même à sa
main et que des facto on a on n'a pas
nécessairement cette agilité nécessaire
dans un temps où il faut de l'agilité
des réponses immédiates parce que les
mers et les élus sont de plus en plus
confrontés à l'exigence de leur
concitoyens et je pense que si on ne
crée pas cette agilité convaincue et
vous l'avez dit que tous les ingrédients
sont là pour que ça fonctionne je crains
malheureusement qu'on ne creuse encore
un peu plus le fauteuil entre ce quel
état aujourd'hui la perception qu'en ont
les élus et cette petite musique de
désespérance qu'on a qu'on a entendu un
peu partout quoi
moi j'espère par mes propos vous avoir
si ce n'est convaincu en tout cas vous
avoir démontré que
ce que l'on soutient au ministère de
l'intérieur c'est justement ces notions
de déconcentration d'agilité de pouvoir
confier au préfet alors après l'État
central
moi je l'ai jamais rencontré en fait ce
qu'on rencontre dans les
et ces saints à la limite il y a des
débats interministériels et puis à un
moment donné il y a des arbitrages qui
sont rendus dans des réunions
interministérielles
et on l'a connu au moment de la loi 3DS
c'est vrai que cette notion de
déconcentration
est une notion ou certains ministères
s'en méfient alors j'essaye de
l'expliquer également il y a peut-être
la crainte
du pouvoir hégémonique du préfet on a
des on charrie nous les préfets une
réputation
[Musique]
ou parfois les ministères se méfient de
nous en disant mais le préfet va
s'accaparer tous les pouvoirs il va
s'autonomiser enfin préfet fonctionne
c'est ce que je dis à mes collègues qui
exercent dans d'autres ministères
d'abord je leur redis toujours je leur
rappelle ce que dit la Constitution les
préfets sont pas les préfets du ministre
de l'intérieur les préfets sont les
représentants de forcément du
gouvernement donc il faut les utiliser
il faut leur faire confiance en fait il
y a cette notion de confiance qui est
parfois sans doute un peu difficile et
les préfets rapporteront ensuite au
ministre
mais
sans doute que la techno structure les
administrations centrales les directions
régionales également
sont
parfois frileuse de de confier un
certain nombre de responsabilités au
préfet de département et ça s'est
accentué l'une de mes marottes mais ça
s'est accentué notamment
quand vous parliez la désespérance ou de
la notion de dénuement ou d'abandon avec
deux phénomènes qui se sont conjugués à
un moment donné toujours dans cette
décennie 2010-2020 c'est par rapport à
la relation au préfet de région la
création des grandes régions
ce phénomène était sans doute moins
présent enfin moi je l'ai vécu j'ai vécu
la par exemple la région
Languedoc-Roussillon qui avait une
cohérence ou avec cinq départements
peut-être pas tous les mers mais les
élus pouvaient avoir accès au préfet de
région la région Occitanie qui va des
Hautes-Pyrénées au Gard
moi j'ai connu sa création vous n'avez
plus cette proximité elle se perd quand
j'étais j'ai exercé comme secrétaire
général de la préfecture de l'Aube en
Champagne-Ardenne avec un une région à 4
départements il y avait de la cohérence
historique géographique une proximité
est-ce que demande moi ce qui m'a frappé
c'est que les mères
ont l'impression quand vous dites d'être
seul c'est qu'ils perd ses échelons de
proximité et c'est conjugué avec ça en
effet la création des grandes
intercommunalités
où les schémas départementaux de
coopération intercommunale je l'ai vécu
en arrivant dans les
Alpes-de-Haute-Provence on crée de
grandes intercommunalités qui parfois
ont surpris les mers
avec des des assemblées intercommunales
importantes et ça ça
tout ceci c'est réduction des effectifs
agencification création des grandes
régions création des grandes
intercommunalités tout ça c'est cumulé
en fait on a en un laps de temps
relativement court quand on y songe
des référents on commence à je pense que
la réflexion la prise de conscience elle
est là
[Musique]
le mouvement des gilets jaunes a joué un
rôle et puis ensuite le grand débat
national a joué un rôle
révélateur en la matière ou désormais
enfin moi je le sens en administration
centrale c'est désormais défendu par les
premiers ministres successifs et par le
Président de la République la notion de
proximité et et
d'importance de l'échelon départemental
et vraiment redevenu sur le sur le
devant de la scène après il faut aussi
convaincre les autres ministères
qui eux restent beaucoup sur une
cinétique s'appuyant sur essentiellement
le régions
très bien merci beaucoup je vous ai pas
répondu mais je vous répondrai dans le
questionnaire sur les démissions d'élus
qui
qui font l'objet de beaucoup de de
commentaires on vous répondra par le
menu
sur les démissions d'élus notamment s'il
fallait donner une idée c'est que dans
les cycles il y a toujours beaucoup de
démission d'élus en début de mandat
et puis généralement ça ça a tendance à
se tarir à mi-mandat est-ce qu'on
constate sur le mandat actuel c'est
qu'on n'a pas plus de démission d'élus
que lors de la mandature précédente en
revanche là où il faut et on n'a pas
toujours les données c'est pourquoi en
démissionne c'est là où les motifs de
démission sont parfois différents par
rapport à ce qu'on a connu sur la
mandature précédente le nombre est le
même mais les motifs sont parfois
différents et la difficulté c'est que
dans notre système d'information qui est
le répertoire national des élus sous la
mandature précédente nous n'étudions pas
autant dans le détail les motifs nous ne
le faisons que depuis cette mandature là
où on a maintenant 11 motifs de
démission qui permettent de suivre
beaucoup plus dans le détail les
motivations qui expliquent à un moment
donné la démission d'un maire notamment
parce que c'est ce qui fait le plus
parler et donc on apportera évidemment
toutes ces précisions dans le
questionnaire
vous adressera pendant nos réponses à
votre questionnaire très bien merci
beaucoup pour cette audition et puis
rendre merci à nos collègues présents et
rendez-vous ce soir pour l'audition du
directeur de la NCT